it's the season as we go the other way
on the break welcome to the NBA Hooker
Collins news the gold pin I mean they're
not even you're not watching the ball go
through inside what a pass
Collins again great hands nice save
short hands including John Collins is
23rd in three-point percentage I know
they want to be a lot better than that
because a lot of times they move the
ball collect it and get it on my way
down that's how well the elevate he got
this monsters dunk right there great
Ally who he finished he didn't stay down
there and celebrate he let the ball go
he got back down on the court on the
defense in and try to make a play in it
but great aggressiveness by the big
fella attention about a minute before he
went over the bench man get that
relationship with the hip
Oh rip that's something special right
there rip man this right here right here
with super impressive right there rifles
through Joe shoulder out of socket right
there him sentimentally son he gives you
great outfit he's unselfish reap looking
lefty stroke Joe Chi positions number 41
is in for Cleveland he committed the
last foul but see Lou going deep in the
fans baby
Lana trying to stay with these guys to
tend to play in the period Taylor
[Applause]
cause this goes baseline off the handle
Hawks swarming defense again taking it
away from cousins
here's Bay's
again cousins trying to do too much
getting in traffic gets a 7th tunnel
beam again you get forward defenders
around where are you going there's
nowhere to go sky-high Gordon to cook
you will toss it up these are fish e8
acute vaginas he'll join your world the
ham
[Applause]
Torian purse on John the Baptist is back
gets the LOB and flushed it proper at
Phillips
right 40:23 to play in the quarter well
we got a lot of games played tonight so
we'd love to be there for that yeah
finally gets that first pass into the
night Malcolm will fire College jumps it
[Applause]
John Collins with the offensive rebound
and throws it down right over Mickey we
look at this rebound here he got it in
the face yes he sure did and look at
this throw down over Mickey the point of
concern for coach Atkinson Brooklyn
averages 15 of nights
[Applause]
didn't cover days with 11 points three
assists John Collins with a big chance
but it's to Orleans on top 54:35 awesome
running that pick and roll against a
Dwight Howard be good by deaf man on the
steel Hawk to running
[Applause]
what depe with the LOB and John Collins
bullshot 8685 magic Dennis of the
pick-and-roll Cowan's with the jam
Collins don't know the nice picking
ruled by Dennis and Collins go right to
the basket nothing in mine but finishing
at the rim and they tell me other way it
comes Dennis with terrific dunk tacking
on more 35
[Applause]
it's seven tonnes 35 points oh yeah man
is John Collins perky Otter Lake Forest
10 on the shot clock
while kicking it back at Fritz intercept
well he should have taken to one-on-one
against them much bigger Torian as he
brought the back of Westbrook for the
jam my goodness I mean Bell goes up to
knock that ball away and John goes over
the top of them to throw that one down
John the Baptist going to work here
closer than he this goes up over against
Lakeland the Orlando Magic G League
affiliate one game to advance Collins
again with a monster throwdowns
the corner Torian crosses over Baxter
[Applause]
look at the powered is the proof force
that John Collins jammed
take it home big fella comets on the
handoff Troy gives it back to look at
this lob right on time and right on
target
76 58
ray Applebaum Catalan starts attending
gets pound a perfect pass and Collins
right there - one hand at home Paul
George you get this up a little far away
into the corner Anderson
[Applause]
five incredible points that is amazing
[Applause]
tonight comics - pepperidge murder with
the long lead to Collins and John puts
it in and he gets a easy look that's
seven first quarter points Majin nice
baseline jam we say goodbye to Brook
Lopez on six pounds John Collins takes
the bump right there and this finishes
at the rim that's a good call tips away
but into the hands of prey back to
college
[Applause]
yes it's let's hit those two threes he
is going to be gone for a while and
there's the one hander to John Colin and
a speedster the self-proclaimed fastest
player the NBA here at Fox
taking it all right he's he's mind
sleeps in the dumb kind of sense man I'm
telling you
let's take another look at that dunk by
John Collins
here's a while stat about John Collins
he's one of nine players in the NBA to
average 19 and 9 10 points right now for
Jason Tatum's the steal - that is the
Aaron Fox comes away with it
oh you better call Omar because that
one's gonna be fun house the highlights
Tom Collins throw it at home we got one
minute left in the half
USA has got a ten-point lead one more
time
he's starin
this guy nothing man do
Rising Stars Challenge it is us each
team needs an answer some beers it is
getting in today from the US 18 right
now
Estrella let's take another look from
Trey young spin around John Kahler gray
survey is the double strain
[Applause]
timeout Minnesota schism out of their
seats at State Farm
[Applause]
man what a play that's wouldn't give the
airspace tray Allah know that John
Collins is going to roll up there among
the dunk leaders this one off the rim
he'll had it blocked picked up by Kevin
hurt her
[Applause]
Kevin off the two screen
[Applause]
but look at the set up by Kevin hurt
pennpoint man he goes up and winds it up
and throws it down when I brought me out
my seat and when they're scared or 1 to
10 this dog here 10 and a half
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content